اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم
مشاهدينا الى الخامسه نستعرض فيها مجموعه
من الملفات وهذه عناوينها
عشيه ذكرى الاولى للحرب كوتيني يهدد بنشر
اسلحه النوويه
في تبعات الزلزال المدمر تركيا توسع
التحقيق مع مقاول البناء وازمه ايجارات
تتصاعد
في تحدي للصين واشنطن تخطط لتوسيعي وجود
قواتها في تايوان خلال اشهر
عندي
بالقرار المشحف
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى تفاصيل نبدا هذه
النشره من اوكرانيا فمع دخول الحرب على
مشارف عامها الثاني ما زالت تشكل الحدث
الابرز على ساحه الدوليه حيث تبقى حاله
الترقب تلازم مجرياتها والنتائج التي
ستنتهي اليها وفي تحدي جديد قال رئيس
روسيا فلاديمير بوتين ان بلاده ستول
اهتماما متزايدا لتعزيز قواتها النوويه من
خلال نشر صاروخ باليسي عابر للقارات تاخر
نشره كثيرا وصواريخ اسرع من الصوت وغواصات
نوويه جديده واشار بوتين الى استعداده
لتقويض اسس الحد من الاسلحه النوويه ما لم
يتراجع الغرب عن التدخل في اوكرانيا وفي
خطاب بمناسبه عيد حماه الوطن قال بوتين ان
روسيا ستواصل تجهيز قواتها المسلحه بمعدات
المطوره لضمان سيادتها واضاف بوتين انه
سيتم نشر صور خبر اصطيعه للقارات من طراز
سارمات هذا العام
[موسيقى]
هذا مشاهدينا ولم ينتظر كثيرا الرد عن او
من اوكرانيا على تصريحات بوتين حيث قال
الرئيس الاوكراني اوكرانيا ستنتصر على
القوات الروسيه في نهايه المطاف واضاف ان
اوكرانيا لن تنكسر وتخطط الكثير من
المحنوه في طريقها للنصر ومحاسبه من جلب
الحرب الى بلاده بحسب قوله
مع حلول ذكرى الاولى للحرب يقول سكان كييف
انهم لا يزالون يعيشون وسط مخاوف حيث
وصفوا هذا العام بانه الاصعب في حياتهم
المتابع
لقد كان اصعب عاما في حياتي وفي حياتي
جميع الاوكرانيين انا متاكده من ان النصر
قريب لكننا بانتظاره لا نعرف متى سياتي
ولا نعرف عدد الارواح التي ستفقد قبل ان
يحدث وهذا هو الشيء الوحيد الذي يقلق جميع
الاوكرانيين الان
كيف يمكنك الشعور بالرضا هنا اذا مات احد
تعرفه كل يوم اصدقائي في مدن اخرى يكتبون
لي عن انفجارات وسقوط ضحايا مقربين كانوا
اصدقاء عمرهم او زملائهم في الدراسه
كنا خائفين في البدايه لكن بعد الخوف جاء
الايمان خاصه في جيشنا قواتنا تحارب في
هذا الصراع منذ فتره طويله لذا فهي تمتلك
مهارات مهنيه جيده لا شك في انها لن تهزم
او تستسلم
وفي هذه الاثناء حملت الخارجيه الروسيه
اوكرانيا والدول الغربيه مسؤوليه فشل
التسويه والوصول الى نهايه للحرب في
اوكرانيا وقال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
ميخائيل جالوزين قال في مقابله مع وكاله
ان احتمالات التوصل الى تسويه لا تزال
بعيده بالنظر الى تصريحات التي تعبر عن
عزله كامله عن الحقائق بحسب تعبيره واضاف
جالوزين ان الحوار مع سيلنسكي صعب
لاعتماده المطلق على الغرب الذي منع بدوره
اي مفاوضات جوهريه ذات معنى وشدد نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه على ضروره اعتراف
والدول الغربيه بالواقع الجو سياسي الحالي
والاعتراف بالمناطق الروسيه الجديده
والقاء السلاح كشرط للعوده الى طويله
المفاوضات
نتحول مباشره الى هذه الكلمه للرئيس
الاوكراني
المفاوضات التي يمكن ان تحقق انجازات
تاريخيه ونحن نعتمد على الدعم الذي يرمي
لتحقيق اهدافنا الاستراتيجيه
بحيث يتم ضمان بيئه امنه وهذا لا لن يحدث
الا من خلال
تكامل
حقيقي بين ضفتين الاطلسي وكنت قد طالبت
كافه الشركاء بالانخراط في عمليه تنفيذ
خطتي السلام
المعنيه باوكرانيا
وشاطرنا بعض النقاط
وبعض
الاوجه المتعلقه بالمساعدات بحيث يمكن
النظر بخطه السلام لتحقيق السلام والنظام
العالمي وكل هذه الامور قد تم التشديد
عليها
بحيث تكون ضمن ميثاق الامم المتحده
لان كل دول العالم ترغبوا بان يتم تحقيق
السلام
وامل ان تستطيع اسبانيا ان تضم ان تنضم
الى هذه الجهود العالميه التي ترمي الى
تحقيق السلام وجعل الغزاه
يتحملون المسؤوليه عما اقترفوه في
اوكرانيا
وكنا قد تطرقنا في اجتماعنا الى اليه
التعويض التي يمكن تطبيقها
وانني ممتن لكم لايجاد الوقت للتطرق لكافه
هذه المواضيع هذا الامر كله
يعود الفضل فيه
لاتفاق زعماء العالم
ورؤيتهم بام اعينهم
لنتائج
للنتائج التي خلفها العدوان الروسي
هذه نقطه مهمه للغايه
لبلادنا ولكافه دول العالم
ان نقدم الدعم والمساعده
من خلال ايجاد الاليه
للمساءله
انعدام العداله ولابد من ايجاد بيئه امنه
لعوده المواطنين والبنى التحتيه هذه واحده
من القضايا التي تطرقنا اليها وخطه
التعافي السريعه لاوكرانيا
وكيفيه تسهيل اماكن التعليم واوجه العمل
كلها
مسائل مهمه تطرقنا اليها سوف تكون تاريخيا
لكافه العالم اشكركم على مفاوضتكم وشكرا
على
زيارتكم الثانيه التي تعد في غايه الاهميه
واشكر كل مواطن اسباني على مساعدته وعلى
حسن الضيافه للمواطنين الاوكرانيين
والان الى الكلمه
الى كلمه رئيس اسبانيا شكرا جزيلا على
دعوتي للحضور الى كيف في هذا اليوم المهم
انني ممتن
لدعوه الى القدوم
والتي تصادف
في ايام الذكرى السنويه الاولى لهذه الحرب
كما تعلمون اسبانيا قد عبرت عن دعمها
الكامل لاوكرانيا في مواجهه حرب بوتين
العدائيه
نشهد مره ثانيه
انعداما للاخلاقيات
وعرقله للنظام العالمي
بسبب هذه الحرب
وكنت قد كررت
للرئيسكي والدول الاتحاد الاوروبي بان نقف
مع اسبانيا وماضون في دعمكم طالما
سوف يكون الامر ضروريا
واوكرانيا سوف تنتصر
اسبانيا تدين باشد اللغه باشد الكلمات هذا
العدوان الروسي ولا يمكننا ان نقبل
ما اقترفته روسيا من جرائم
سنكتفي بهذا القدر كنا في متابعه هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي للرئيس الاوكراني
ومعه زياره مهمه على اثر دعوه كما قال
رئيس الوزراء الاسباني في فتره مهمه هي
فتره او عشيه ذكرى السنه على بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه والحرب
الاوكرانيه
نتحدث عن ضروره ايجاد حلول بما يتوافق مع
مواثيق الامم المتحده وقال بان المجتمع
الدولي عليه محاسبه الغازات كما وصف
الجانب الروسي كذلك رئيس وزراء الاسباني
تحدث عن ضروره ايجاد حلول لهذه الحربه
الاوكرانيه هناك كذلك تفاصيل اخرى اكيد
باننا سنعود لها ولكن لاحقا اما في هذه
النشره او في متابعتنا
لكل هذه التطورات نتابع الان من على الارض
من كييف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بك
ومن موسكو مراسل
ان ابدا من اوكرانيا معك حذيفه حذيفه
الحرب تغير وجوه المجتمعات نحن عشيه
الذكرى السنويه للحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
او للعمليه العسكريه كما تسميها روسيا كيف
تغير وجه كياف واوكرانيا خلال سنه
نعم تحياتي لك ولزميل عبد الجواد في
الحقيقه اذا سمحت لي ان انقل انطباعي عن
اليوم وهو اليوم الاخير الذي يعني ينتظر
الجميع ما الذي سيحدث كيف ستكون كيف سيكون
الفعل وليس رده الفعل من قبل الاتحاد
الروسي في هذه الذكرة كان هنالك يعني حديث
واسع من قبل السلطات الاوكرانيه حول انه
سوف يكون هنالك استهداف وقلق كبير من
المواطنين اليوم اولا لاحظت ان الشوارع
يعني هي ليست حركه السير ليست المعتاده
ولا يوجد ازدحام في العاصمه كيف الذي يعني
احتدناه هنا في العاصمه كيف وهذا يدل على
ماذا يدل على ان اغلبيه المواطنين او عدد
كبير من المواطنين اليوم ذهبوا الى
الضواحي او خرجوا الى منازلهم في الريف
لينتظروا هذه الذكرة وينتظر ما الذي يمكن
ان يحدث هنالك اجراءات واسعه طبقت من قبل
المواطنين لانفسهم وهو البقاء في مناطق
قريبه من الملاجئ والابتعاد عن المناطق
التي يمكن استهدافها من قبل الروسي وهنالك
اجراءات من السلطات في الحكم المحلي في
المدن وفي القرى وفي المحليات المختلفه
كتجهيز الملاجئ وايضا نقل الدراسه الى
الوضع الافتراضي تغيرت العاصمه بشكل كبير
يعني سالتني عن التغيير العاصمه كانت شبه
خاليه هنالك عوده كبيره حدثت وهنالك
الاعمال التجاريه عادت والنشاط عاد ولكن
طبعا مع ذلك لا يمكن ان نصف ان النهايه
عادت بشكل طبيعي الى العصير هناك شيء من
الارتباك فداخل الاوكراني وهناك شيء من
الانتظار تحدثت عنه وكانه هناك مخاوف وهنا
سؤال عبد الجواد هل ننتظر شيء معين غدا من
الجانب الروسي او لا جديد يذكر في هذا
الاطار
مرحبا ريم لك والد زميل حذيفه اليوم ليست
هي كما كانت قبل نحو عام من الان طبعا
الشيء المنتظر اليوم نلاحظ بان موسكو خلال
الايام الاخيره الماضيه تمارس عمليه القاء
التهم باتجاه الغرب
طبعا بهذا الشيء نفسه ان كان بين الرئيسين
الروسي والامريكي ان كان اليوم كما نلاحظ
على لسان من بيدف الحديث اصبح يدور في
المدن الروسيه وفي العاصمه حول استراتيجيه
روسيا العسكريه حول يعني ترسانتها النوويه
حول تهيئه الجيش ودعمه بكافه انواع السلاح
التخبط الداخلي الكبير ان كان على المستوى
العسكري او كان على مستوى الفصائل التي
تقاتل في جنوب الاوكراني الجميع اصبح يعرف
الاتهامات التي رماها طبعا قائد مجموعه
فاغنر على وزاره الدفاع وكيف قامت وزاره
الدفاع موسكو بالرد على هذا لذلك طبعا لا
يمكن الحديث عن ان الوضع هو طبيعي في
العاصمه موسكو لكن طبعا لا يمكن الحديث عن
ان موسكو تعاني بشكل كبير هذا بما يخص
طبعا العمليه العسكريه نلاحظ بان موسكو
تصعد من جديد من ضرباتها قد نشهد منذ صباح
يوم الغد تطور اكثر وتسارع وتصعيد في
ضربات موسكو العسكريه ان كانت صاروخيه وان
كانت مدفعيه وان كانت في تحليق لمقاتلاتها
ومروحيتها لكن طبعا الوضع على الارض في
المدن الروسيه الداخليه هو شبه طبيعي بشكل
كبير اما الشريط الحدودي المنتخب بالاراده
الاوكرانيه فهو يشهد طبعا سقوط قذائف سقوط
صواريخ عمل انظمه الدفاع الجويه حاله من
التوتر تعيشها تلك المناطل حول تلك المدن
الى تكنات عسكريه هذا بما يخص الامر
العسكري والسياسي لكن طبعا الوضع
الاقتصادي الجميع اصبح يعرف بان موسكو
تعاني بشكل كبير من العقوبات الكبيره ان
كانت على مستوى البنوك والمصارف والشركات
التي هو ايجاد حلول بديله لكنها لم تصرخ
بشكل كبير ما زالت الحياه
يعني المدينه هي اليوم بخلاف مدينه كييف
نوعا ما الشيء الوحيد المشترك بينهما هو
ان المدينه فارغه باعتبار ان اهل المدن
متعودون على السفر الى خارجها في ايام
العطل واليوم هو عيد الجيش عيد من خدمه في
القوات المسلحه الروسيه صحيح على كل الوضع
السياسي كما العسكري والاقتصادي كذلك
سيبقى موضوع اهتمام متابعتنا في هذه
الساعات القادمه ولكن اعود لك حذيفه حذيفه
في بدايه هذه الحرب مراقبون استبعدوا ان
تمتد لاشهر فما بالك بالسنه لم يتوقع احد
بان هذه الحرب قد تطول وهي مستمره حتى
الان وليست هناك حلول في الافق وبالتالي
كيف استوعب الاوكرانيون هذه الفكره وبداوا
شيئا فشيئا يتعايشون معها
نعم اولا عندما بدات ريم هذه الحرب يعني
لم يكن احد يتوقع ان الاوكرانيين سيصمد في
وجه الجيش الروسي اسبوع او اسبوعين على
الاكثر ويمكن ان يكون الجيش الروسي داخل
العاصمه الاوكرانيين يفاجئوا الجميع
بصمودهم بالوقوف والدفاع عن بلادهم في
الحقيقه القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في ذلك
التاريخ عندما بدات الحرب حتى اعداد
الجنود لم تكن الاعداد الكافيه لمجابهه
الجيش الروسي ولكن المواطنين الاوكرانيين
الشعب الاوكراني سارع بالاندماج في الجيش
وسارع بالتطوع لذلك اصبحت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بهذا الحجم الذي يدافع الان عن
الاراضي الاوكراني هذا من جانب طبعا ايضا
هنالك الجانب الاقتصادي لولا الدعم
الاقتصادي الكبير اليوم دينيسيس ميغال
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني تحدث في مؤتمر
صحفي وقال ان العجز اصبح 38 مليون دولار
في ميزانيه الدوله وقال ان ميزانيه الدوله
قبل الحرب بالكامل تذهب الى الجيش ونحن
نعيش يعني تسير الحياه تسير الدوله عن
طريق المساعدات من الشركاء فاذا لولا وقوف
شركاء كيف معها اقتصاديا لما استطاعت ان
تستمر اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب ايضا على
الصعيد العسكري لولا الدعم العسكري الكبير
الذي سمح حتى باستعاده الاراضي بعد ان
سيطره روسيا على مناطق واسعه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه حتى انها وصلت حتى حدود
العاصمه اكيد اذا الدعم الغربي والدعم من
الشركاء هو كان له يعني الفضل الاكبر في
ان تصمت كيف في وجه القوات الروسيه
وتستطيع ان تستعيد الاراضي الاوكرانيين
طبعا هم قلقون ولكنهم ما زالوا يقولون
اننا لا يوجد لدينا خيار ما دمنا ندافع عن
اراد وضحت الفكره على كل متابعه العربيه
ستبقى مستمره لفصول هذه المرحله من الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه عشيه ذكرها الاولى
شكرا جزيلا لزملائنا من اكياف مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل ومن موسكو العربيه عبد
الجواد
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى الخلف قبل عام
تحديدا حينما ارسل بوتين قواته لاوكرانيا
في مكانها يفترض ان تكون عمليه خاطفه كما
وصفت لكن الهجوم امتدا الى حرب شامله ما
جعل فكره الانتصار ابعد مما كان متوقعا
قتل الالاف ونزح مثلهم فيما دمرت مدن
كامله ولم تستطع موسكو السيطره على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه بعد ففي شرق اوكرانيا
وهي ابرز جبهات القتال سخونه في الوقت
الراهن تحاول مجموعه
لروسيا للاستيلاء على باخموت منذ اكثر من
سته اشهر دون نتيجه لكن الكريملين لم
يستسلم او لا يستسلم ويصر على استمرار
القتال حولها بحسب التقارير مشاهدينا
بخموت لا تحمل اهميه استراتيجيه لكن احكام
القبض عليها لرمزيتها السياسيه والمعنويه
بدا امرا مهما قبيل معركه كبيره متوقعه في
الربيع فالاستيل على بخمه بنسبه للروس امر
مهم حيث سيمهد الطريق للتقدم الى اكبر
مدينتين في الغرب هما غراماتورسكا من جهه
اخرى لم تخف القياده او تخفي القياده
الاوكرانيه طموحاتها في استعاده الاراضي
بما في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم بحسب صحيفه
الجاردين البريطانيه
سنه على الحرب الاوكرانيه لكن اوكرانيا لم
تحرر اراضيها وروسيا لن تزيح الحكومه
الاوكرانيه
نحو 20% من الاراضي الاوكرانيه تحت قبضه
موسكو روسيا سيطرت على مساحات شاسعه من
منطقتي خرسون وذاكوريجيا وتقريبا على كل
لوجانسك وعلى نحو نصف
واعلنت ايضا من جانب واحد ضمها لاربع
مناطق اوكرانيه من جهه اخرى تكبدت روسيا
ثلاث انتكاسات كبيره في ساحات المعارك فمن
هو الفائز بالحرب الامر غير واضح حتى الان
نتابع دائما رصد الاوضاع الميدانيه من
ازيوم وفد العربيه احمد بجاتو بداتو اهلا
بك معنا بالامس كنت في خركيف اليوم اتجهت
شرقا الى
كيف او ما هي مشاهداتك الاوليه عند وصولك
الى هذه المنطقه التي شهدت معارك دارها في
السابق كانت تسيطر عليها روسيا وفيما بعد
عادت للحضن الاوكراني
نعم ريم اهلا بك يعني بالفعل وصلنا
كما يسميها الاوكران هنا
هذا المكان الذي سيطروا هذه المدينه التي
سيطر عليها القوات الروسيه لمده تزيد عن
سبعه اشهر كامله دمرت فيها اغلب مناطق
المدينه المكان الذي اقف فيه ليس لم نقف
هنا
في اي مكان نحن وقفنا امام هذه الغابه
التي تحوي احد اكبر المقابر الجماعيه هنا
في اوكرانيا كنا نحاول ان نقف داخل هذه
المقابر لكن يعني جوده الانترنت ان تسمح
لنا بذلك لذلك وقفنا امام هذه الغابه التي
تحوي اكثر من 436 جثه من المدنيين الذين
قام الجنود الروس بدفنهم في مقابر جامعيه
في هذا المكان
نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من الفريق قتيل خلال
عام من القتيل المدني فقط خلال عام الحرب
فقط على هذه المدينه وجدنا العديد من
الجسور التي تم
قامت القوات الاوكرانيه وتدمير هذه الجسور
لتمنع وصول التعزيزات والمعدات الى الجنود
الروس الذين كانوا موجودين في هذه المدينه
العديد من الجسور ما زال ما زال يعني مدمر
للغايه ولا يوجد نيه لاعاده ترميم او بناء
هذه الجسور مره اخرى لم نجد مواطنين يمشون
في الشارع الا قليلا للمواطنين لديه
تحدثنا معهم يعني وجدنا احدى الموتورات
تتحدث عن ان الطائرات
شاهدت بعينها الطائرات تقوم الطائرات
المروحيه تقوم بضرب المدنيين بالرشاشات
قتل في هذه الحادثه التي يتحدث عنها
السيده اكثر من عشرين او ثلاثين قتيلا كما
تقول نحن نتحدث عن مدينه هي مدينه هامه
للغايه لذلك هناك تخوف من قبل المواطنين
ان يعود الروس مره اخرى للسيطره عليها
سمعنا ذوي الصافات الانذار اكثر من مره
سمعنا اصوات القصف اكثر من مره اكثر
الاوكراني
المدينه ليقوم بنفسه برفع العلم الاوكراني
مره اخرى على هذه ولكن لماذا هذه المخاوف
هل هناك الشبكات على اطراف هذه المدينه
مواطنون هنا جربوا جربوا هذا الامر من قبل
مع مع الروس الروس يريدون الوصول الى هذه
المدينه ومن ثم الانتقال الى خاركيف وسط
مدينه خاركيف لذلك هي بلده هامه للغايه
لذلك يكون هناك تخوف كبير من قبل
المواطنين هنا وايضا حشود عسكريه كبيره
يعني حشود عسكريه كبيره موجوده هنا لكن
دعيني نتحدث عن نقطه
حول الجنود الاوكراني والقوات الاوكرانيه
الموجوده في الشرق هذه هذه القوات هي اكثر
قدرات خبره قتاليه في اوكرانيا على
الاطلاق كونها تحارب منذ عام 2014 مع
القوات الانفصاليه الموجوده في اقليم
دومباس لذلك القوات هنا مختلفه او يعني هي
اكثر درايه بالقتال مع الروس اكثر من اي
قوات موجوده في الجبهات الاخرى لذلك الحرب
هي حرب شرسه للغايه فقط هنا ايضا في زوم
فقط او في المناطق المجاوره وانما ايضا في
دنييتسكو هؤلاء هؤلاء الجنود هم الاكثر
درايه والخبره في قتال الروس نظرا للفتره
الطويله التي قضاها في القتال معهم
في تغطيه الغد عد لنا سالما احمد بجاتو
موفد العربيه كان معنا من ايزيوم شكرا
جزيلا لك
نتابع دائما في نفس هذا الاطار ولكن
ميدانيا تضغط روسي على الارض حيث اعلنت
موسكو ان الجيش الروسي هجم مناطق لمان
وكوبيانس وكبد الجيش الاوكراني خسائر
بشريه بلغت نحو 500 جندي حيث اشار مستشار
القائم باعمل الرئاسه في جمهوريه كنفصاليه
التابعه لروسيا ان سيطره على مدينه بخموت
باتت قريبه
نشير فقط العاج الكره نتابعه اسفل الشاشه
منذ قليل ياسر يقول ان هناك اشارات على ان
الصين ربما ترسل اسلحه الى روسيا فيما
الان وزير الدفاع الروسي يقول ان محاولات
الغرب لتمزيق روسيا مصيرها الفشل تتصاعد
التصريحات مع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه لهذه
الحرب والاكيد باننا سنبقى في متابعه
للتفاصيل الميدانيه وكذلك حتى هذه
التصريحات السياسيه في تحدي ان روسيا اخر
كذلك ربما خارج الميدان يبدو ان الخلاف
الذي ظهر مؤخرا بين مجموعه فاجنر وقياده
الجيش الروسي بدات تتلاشى حيث اعلن رئيس
مجموعه فاغنر المعروف باسم الطباخ بوتين
يفديني اعلن بدء قواته تلقي امدادات
اضافيه من الذخيره بعد يوم فقط من
انتقادات وجهها لقاده الجيش
[موسيقى]
الخامسه مستمره معكم وفيها بعد الفاصل
محكمه المانيه تقضي بالسجن مدى الحياه على
سوريا فلسطيني وملقب بجزار اليرموك
نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد نستكمل الخامسه
من تداعيات الزلزال المدمر حيث قال وزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان سويلم ان بلاده
سيتوسع التحقيق ضد مقاول للبناء المشتبهي
في انتهاكهم معايير السلامه وذكر صويلو
انهم حددوا هويه
564 مشتبها به حتى الان واعتقلوا 160 فيما
تتواصل التحقيقات مع عدد اكبر بكثير
وتتزامن هذه التحقيقات مع تكثيف تركيا خطط
بناء مساكن لضحايا زلزالها المدمر
[موسيقى]
مشكله اخرى تواجه تركيا في اعقاب الزلزال
حيث اشارت الصحف المحليه الى ان ارتفاع
الايجارات قد يتحول الى ازمه اجتماعيه
حقيقيه لان اجراءات الحكومه لم تتمكن من
وقف ارتفاع الاسعار بعد تزايد الطلب بسبب
الزلزال في وقت سابق وصف وزير الداخليه
التركي سليمان سويلم الزياده الحاده في
اسعار ايجارات الشقق في البلاد بعد زلزال
المدمر في جنوب شرق البلاد بالعار
واعتبرها خطيئه كبيره
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت داخليه التركيه منع
دخول المواطنين الى البيوت المتضرره من
الزلزال خشيه انهيارها مع استمرار الهزات
الارضيه في المناطق المنكوبه وعلى الرغم
من تشديد وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان
سويلم على ذلك بالمنع التام تحت طائله
المسؤوليه يخاطر البعض في ذلك لاخراج
اغراضهم مثلا ومستلزمتهم كذلك مفرد
العربيه رصد المشهد من بلده سمنداغ
بضواحيها طاي نتابع
رغم اقرار الداخليه التركيه بمنع دخول اي
مواطن الى هذه البنايات المهدمه لكنهم ومع
هدوء الارض من الهزات الارتداديه يسارعون
الخطى لاقتناء واخراج مقتنياتهم او ما
امكنهم من اخراج ذلك
مرحبا شيخ مرحبا
ايش تعملوا من نزل البيت الاغراض البيت
القديم لتحت الجديد
خطر اعتقد انه البنايه البنايه قائله
للسقوط صح اي نعم
لكن كان في قرار السلطات بانه يمنع اي
واحد
بيدخلوا
مصاري كثير هذا
اللزم يحسن ما يشيل من جوا من البيت
اضرار خفيفه مش مش كثيره نعم
ما نحسن
هلا هون هون
يعني هناك
بحذر يقومون باخراج اغراضهم خوفا من حدود
زلزال اخر او هزه قويه قد تاتي على هذه
البنايه وما فيها من اغراض
يعتبرونها كل ما تبقى لهم من ذكريات قبل
ان يضرب الزلزال هذه المناطق عبد القادر
خربوش بقناتها العربيه والحدث من ضاحيه
سمنداغ ولايتها
الوضع الانساني صار فيها طاي لنستطلع
الاوضاع في كهربا مرعش كذلك التي كانت
مركز الزلزال الاول مراسل العربيه زيدان
اهلا بك معنا نتابع بان هناك وضع انساني
حتى بعد مرور عده ايام ولكن يبقى الوضع
الانسان صعب وصعب للغايه كيف هي صوره في
كهرباء المرعش
نعم ريم الصوره في كهرمان مرعش متناقضه
حقيقه تجمع النقيضين هناك احياء مدمره او
مساكن مدمره تحاول فرق الانقاذ عفوا
الفرق رفع الانقاض
ازاله الانقاض والركام من هذه المناطق
وهناك مناطق هنا مثلا في مركز المدينه كما
تشاهدين الحياه بدات تعود بشكل تدريجي الى
هذه المناطق ريم بعض المحال افتتح اصحابها
او افتتح بعض اصحاب المحل محلهم مجددا بعض
الابنيه في جوله يوم امس قمنا في بها في
كهرمان مرعش بعض الابنيه خصوصا في الاحياء
الحديثه شاهدنا ان هناك بعض الاشخاص او
بعض العائلات اختاروا العوده الى هذه
المنازل
والبيوت رغم مخاطر الهزات الارتداديه
والخشيه من هزاته فداديه لكن مع ذلك هناك
بعض العائلات فضلت الى منازلها بدلا من ان
تبقى في الخيانه
التركيه تحدثت عن عملها في تامين او في
محاوله تامين مساكن لمن تضررت منازلهم
حدثنا قليلا عن زياده اسعار الايجار هل
هناك محاوله لاستغلال هذه الازمه
نعم كما ذكرتم سليمان صولو وزير الداخليه
وصف هذا الموضوع او هذه القضيه بالعار لكن
حتى هذا الوصف ورغم الاجراءات الحكوميه
للحد من هذه
الظاهره التي بدات الانتشار مؤخرا يبدو ان
الامور تخرج رويدا رويدا عن السيطره حتى
الان هناك ارتفاع اسعار جنوني لا نتحدث عن
المناطق المنكوبه نتحدث عن المناطق التي
خرج اليها متضرري الزلزال انقر اسطنبول
ازمير ولايات الغربيه وايضا شمال البحر
الاسود التقديرات الرسميه تتحدث او عفوا
التقديرات شبهه الرسميه او تقديرات بعض
الوسائل الاعلام التركيه تقول ان مليوني
شخص الان هم بلا ماوى اي اما دمرت منازلهم
بشكل كامل او
تضررت بشكل كبير او هي بحاجه الى هدم او
هم حاليا يخشون العوده الى المنازل ايضا
التقديرات الرسميه تقول بان مليون شخص
غادر هذه الولايات العشره الى الولايات
اكثر امنا هذا شق اول من المشكله نتحدث عن
شق أو هناك شق اخر ساتحدث عنه بعد قليل
الشق الاول هؤلاء الاشخاص او هؤلاء
العوائل التي ذهبوا الى تلك الولايات
الولايات البعيده عن مناطق الزلزال يعانون
حقيقه من ارتفاع الاسعار في تلك الولايات
هناك حاله جشع واستغلال كبير للظروف ظروف
النزوح وقدوم متضررين الزلزال النقطه
الاخرى ونتحدث هنا تحديدا على وجه التحديد
في اسطنبول اسطنبول هناك بعض المناطق لا
شك ان دائما خبراء الزلازل يحذرون من وقوع
زلزال كبير في اسطنبول لذلك هناك الان
هجره داخليه في اسطنبول من المناطق التي
يخشى سكانها انها ستكون عرضه للدمار او
الهدم في حال حدث الزلزال الى المناطق
الحديثه
فقط مثلا باشاك شهير او بيوب هذه المناطق
ايضا شهدت ارتفاع في الاسعار خلال الايام
الماضيه
سيكون محل متابعه في الواقع زيدان لانه قد
يفاقم الازمه ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر اسمح
لي على ان اعود لك في نشرات او نعود لك في
نشرات اخرى زيدان زنكلو العربيه كنت معنا
من مرعش شكرا لك
الزلزال في تركيا هز اراضيها وترك خلفه
نحو 210 ملايين طن من الانقاض فكيف ستتخلص
الحكومه التركيه من انقاض المباني
المنهاره
مرحله البحث والانقاذ الاولى انتهت وخرج
الناجي الاخير من تحت الانقاض بعد نحو
ثلاثمائه ساعه
الان جاء وقت مهمه اخرى شاقه وهي ازاله
الانقاض تنقسم الى ثلاث مراحل الاولى هي
جمع الانقاض ثم صبها في مناطق مخصصه لها
قبل ان يتم فصلها للبدء في اعاده التدوير
برنامج الامم المتحده الاملائي يقول ان
نحو 500 الف منزل سيحتاج لاعاده بناء
بتركيا
ومن بين هذه المباني تم هدم 412 الف شقه
في
1818 الف مبنى
مشاهدينا الوضع في شمال السوري ماساوي مع
تعثر دخول المساعدات الاغاثيه للمتضررين
من جانبها قالت نائبه المبعوث الخاص للامم
المتحده لسوريا نجاه رشدي قالت ان الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد ادى الى ازمه ضمن ازمه
اخرى
[موسيقى]
جينا نبعث رسائل من على هذا الدمار يلي
احدثوا الزلزال
لكل العالم يلي وقفت معنا
[موسيقى]
من مدينه جندريسي ينضم لنا مراسل العربيه
عفوا محمد الاشقر محمد اهلا بك معنا بعد
فتره ربما البعثه تريث فيها وتمكن من فهم
ما يحدث تعثر وصول المساعدات الى ايه
اسباب ترجع
الحقيقه هناك عده اسباب لتاخر وصول
المساعدات الى عموم المناطق المتضرره في
مدينه جنديرس ان تحدثنا بالبدايه عن
المساعدات الامميه فالمساعدات الامميه
اغلبها دخل من عن طريق معبر باب الهواء
الحدودي واخر هذه القوافل دخلت اليوم بعدد
شاحنات وصل الى 47 شاحنه ليرتفع مجموع عدد
الشاحنات المقدمه من الامم المتحده والتي
عبرت معبر باب الهواء الى 273 شاحنه طبعا
ربما
يبدو ان الطرقات وصعوبه الوصول الى عموم
المناطق من من معبر باب الهواء الى
المناطق المتضرره سيريس حلب ربما هو السبب
الاول ويبدو ان غياب الاحصائيه الى حد هذه
اللحظه حول العوائل المتضرره
السبب الثاني طبعا
الهواء الجغرافيا قريب من المناطق
المتضرره في ريف ادلب ولكن
بعيد نوعا ما جغرافيا وكل هذه الاسباب قد
تتعثر تتعثر عمليه وصول مساعده حدثنا عن
المكان حيث تتواجد محمد هناك خيم من
يسكنها ما هي الاعداد من يشرف على ايواءهم
على غذائهم على عمليه التطبيب
نعم نحن الان في احد المخيمات المستحدثه
في مدينه جنديرس الاهالي المتضررون هنا هم
من المدينه او النازحين اليها في وقت سابق
اي انهم من المتضررين الذين تضرروا نتيجه
الكارثه التي اصابت المدينه تم استحداث
هذا المخيم قبل ايام عندما دخلت
اولى القوافل المساعدات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه قافله عندما دخلت وعبرت من معبر
حمام 11
شاحنه ووصلت الى مدينه جنديرس طبعا جميع
المخيمات في عموم مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
تعيش اوضاع انسانيه صعبه تفتقر لادنى
مقومات الحياه هنا في هذا المخيم الى حد
هذه اللحظه تغيب شبكات الصرف الصحي عدد
قليل من خزانات المياه يعني المساعدات تصل
الى حد اللحظه بشكل تدريجي هناك دعوات
طبعا قبل قبل بدء عمليه البث المباشر هذه
وصلتني تحدث معي العديد من
المدنيين المتضررين ان قالوا ان المساعدات
تحتاج لتكثيف وتحتاج لتسريع لحد لان
الازمه كبيره صحيح
بايصال رمق العيش فقط
ستبقى هذه المواضيع للمتابعه شكرا جزيلا
لك محمد الاشقر مراسل العربيه من جنديرس
في سوريا
الى ملف اخر الان وفي تحدي الصين قالت
صحيفه وست جورنال ان الولايات المتحده
ستوسع حجم القوات الامريكيه المنتشره في
تايوان الى نحو اربعه اضعاف لتعزيز برامج
التدريب لجيش الجزيره الذاتيه الحكمه وسط
تصاعد لتهديد الصيني واشارت الى انه
واشنطن تخطط لنشر ما بين 100 الى 200 جندي
على الجزيره في الاشهر المقبله وفقا
لمسؤول امريكي وستقوم القوه الاكبر بتوسيع
برنامج تدريبي بذلت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه جهودا كبيره لابقائه بعيدا عن
العلن فيما تعمل الولايات المتحده لتزويد
تايوان بالقدرات التي تحتاجها للدفاع عن
نفسها دون استفزاز بكينا
قضت المحكمه الاقليميه في برلين مدى
الحياه ضد الفلسطينيه السوري
المتهم باطلاقه قذيفه على تجمع مدني عامه
2014 اثناء استلامهم سلالا غذائيه من
الاونروا في مخيم اليرموك بدمشق وواجهت
المحكمه للمعروف باسم جزار اليرموك
اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه بسبب
مشاركته في الحصار على مخيم اليرموك ما
ادى الى تجويع سكانه
شنت مقاتلات اسرائيليه صباح اليوم غارات
عده على مواقع قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انها
عسكريه تابعه لحركه حماس بعد ان اطلقت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه سته صواريخ على الاقل
من القطاع جرع اعتراضه خمسه منها وفق بيان
الجيش الاسرائيلي وجاءت تصعيد بعد ان قتلت
اسرائيل احد عشر فلسطينيا واصابت نحو 100
بجروح في نابلس شماليه الضفه الغربيه زياد
حلبي وتفاصيل نحن هنا على حدود قطاع غزه
حيث يسود هدوء اعقب عاصفه تمثلت بتبادل
للقصف ما بين الصواريخ الفلسطينيه التي
انطلقت من القطاع والغارات الاسرائيليه
التي اعقبت ذلك على عده مواقع قالت
اسرائيل انها تابعه لحركه حماس ياتي هذا
التصعيد وان كان متوقعا بعد ان قالت
الفصائل بانها سترد على ما وصفته بمجزره
نابلس وفعلا هذا ما كان وياتي ايضا
لمعادله باتت قائمه وهي توحيد الساحات
بمعنى انفجار في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
يقود الى التصعيد على جبهه قطاع غزه
فعمليات فرديه في القدس الشرقيه المحتله
المقاتلات الاسرائيليه ايضا لم تبرح
المنطقه الجنوبيه في اطار التاهب السائد
وفي اطار حاله تاهب على الارض نشرت
اسرائيل المزيد من بطاريات القبه الحديديه
في محيط قطاع غزه وفي المناطق الجنوبيه
الاعتقاد في اسرائيل بان التصعيد سيتواتر
عمليا وصولا الى شهر رمضان المقبل هناك
احتمال بان تندلع مواجهه شامله في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله وكذا ايضا على حدود قطاع
غزه من حيث انفجار الحرب على هذا القطاع
زياد حلبي العربيه حدود قطاع غزه
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نعود من جديد الى
ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه كنا بدانا
هذه النشره بهذا الملف نحن عشيه الذكرى
السنويه الاولى لهذه الحرب ومن الحدود
البولنديه الاوكرانيه مفرد العربيه حسين
قنيبر حسين اهلا بك معنا ما هي او ما هو
اهم ما رصدت عشيه الذكرى السنويه الاولى
اهلا بك ريم تتذكرين جيدا اننا ومنذ عام
تماما كنا هنا عند المعابر الحدوديه التي
تربط اوكرانيا بولندا عده معابر حدوديه
كان من بينها معبر رئيسي هو معبر مديكا
حيث اتواجد الان اترك الكاميرا ترصد
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الواقعه على بعد امتار
من هنا عبر هذا المعبر خصوصا وغيره من
المعابد الحدوديه ولكن خصوصا هذا المعبر
دخل ملايين اللاجئين الاوكرانيين الى
بولندا بعيده اندلاع الحرب في بلدهم حوالي
تسعه ملايين لاجئ اوكراني دخلوا حينها الى
بولندا بقي منهم على الاراضي البولنديه
مليون ونصف المليون لاجئ ما زالوا فيها
حتى الان وتوزع حوالي سبعه ملايين و500
اخر على عده دول اوروبيه موجه النزوح
تراجعت هي تقتصر فقط على بعض العابرين الى
هنا من لفيف في اقصى الغرب الاوكراني
عندما تتعرض لفيف احيانا لقصف روسي وكنا
فيها قبل اشهر وتعرضت حينها للقصف الروسي
تعرضت ايضا قبل شهرين وهي تتعرض لفيف
بانتظام للقصف فيلجا سكان منها الى هنا
الى الجانب البولندي من الحدود تشاهدين
هذه الشاحنات التي لا يتوقف عبورها من
بولندا نحو اوكرانيا بولندا تحولت الى
مكان لعبور كل المساعدات الدوليه خصوصا
الانسانيه والغذائيه والعسكريه نحو داخل
الاوكراني وتشاهدين صف طويل من السيارات
المدنيه
وفي تغطيه العربيه لهذه الذكرى شكرا
العربيه من الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه
الى فاصل من بعدها سنتابع
في تونس الغنوشي يخضع للتحقيق في قضايا
ارهاب بعد يومين من اتهامه بالتحريض على
الشرطه
نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد قالت المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بها او قامت بحظر تطبيق تيك توك
على الجوالات الرسميه التي يستخدمها
الموظفون وسط مخاوف بشان حمايه البيانات
وقال المتحدث ان الحضره يعني ايضا ان
موظفي المفوضيه الاوروبيه لا يمكنهم
استخدام التطبيق الصيني على جوالاتهم
الشخصيه بما في ذلك الهواتف التي تحتوي
على تطبيقات رسميه تابعه للمفوضيه وقال
الاتحاد الاوروبي انه لم يتعرض لضغوط من
واشنطن لحظر التطبيق من جانبها عبارات
شركه تيك توك عن اسفها لقرار المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بما وصفته بالمشحف
في تونس يمثل رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي امام القضاء في ثاني تحقيق له في
اقل من 72 ساعه بيتهم تتعلق بالارهاب ووصل
الغنوشي لسكنه الحرس بالعوينه في العاصمه
تونس للحديث في قضيه قالت حركته انها
مجهوله فيما اشارت تقارير اعلاميه الى
انها تتعلق بلقائه سابقا عناصر من تنظيم
انصار الشريعه الارهابي المحظور في تونس
ونحن كذلك بدورنا نختم هذه النشره ولكن
اخبارنا مستمره على شاشات العربيه على
مدار الساعه وكذلك بالتفصيل على
العربيه. غدا تغطيه للذكرى السنويه
للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
بمجموعه من التفاصيل والتقارير كذلك
ومراسلين على الارض ابقوا معنا وتابعونا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]